smartphones TVs computers iPads and many
other modern miracles are made possible
by power efficient LED screens but the
real impact goes well beyond our
brightly lit gadgets lighting accounts
for 20 to 30 percent of global
electricity consumption and about 6
percent of greenhouse gas emissions
given that LED bulbs use around 80
percent less energy and last 25 times
longer than incandescent lighting they
have the greatest potential impact on
energy savings globally but when the
first LEDs were introduced in the 1960s
they didn't have much use it wasn't
until the 90s when Japanese scientists
discovered the missing link needed to
complete the color spectrum the blue LED
here's how the color blue changed
lighting after Thomas Edison invented
the light bulb in 1879 incandescent
lights lit much of the 20th century the
problem is they waste a lot of energy
lost in the form of heat and they don't
last locked fluorescent lights started
being used in the 1930s although much
more efficient than incandescent they're
not an ideal replacement they contain
toxic mercury aged significantly if
they're frequently switched on and off
and are prone to flicker they needed to
be a better solution in 1961 Garry
Pitman and James R beard of Texas
Instruments accidentally invented the
first practical light-emitting diode
while trying to make a laser diode the
first LEDs emitted infrared light
invisible to the human eye which later
became useful in things like remote
controls and for the next three decades
advances were made to include red and
green but they couldn't quite get to
blue which was needed to make White's
light but the appeal was obvious unlike
ordinary incandescent bulbs LEDs don't
have a filament that will burn out they
don't get hot and they require a lot
less energy so the biggest electronics
companies raced to create a powerful
blue LED but the problem of the missing
color plagued them for nearly
a key ingredient a chemical compound
called gallium nitride proved difficult
to grow in a lab scientists tried and
failed ultimately turning their
attention to other more promising
semiconductor materials for creating
blue light but a number of favourable
circumstances led a scientist from a
small chemical company in Japan called
nicha to finally make the discovery
firstly by virtue of having little to no
budget scientists Shuji Nakamura was
forced to create red and infrared LEDs
from scratch using parts he's scavenged
and fixed by hand most companies in the
80s were creating LED material using
commercially available equipment this
experience which took him around ten
years and featured monthly explosions in
the lab would later prove invaluable
when doing trials for blue LEDs the
second reason was his decision to use
gallium nitride a material considered a
dead end by other scientists but his
motivation for using the chemical
compound was personal getting his ph.d
according to Nakamura writing papers on
less promising candidates for blue
lights would make it much easier for him
to get the necessary papers published
for his degree again he went back to the
lab not taking holidays and not varying
his daily routine but this time was
different he convinced the Chia to buy
the equipment for manufacturing LED
material instead of starting from
scratch he made small modifications to
the commercially available equipment his
extensive experience building red and
infrared LEDs aided the alterations just
over a year later Nakamura made his
first successful growth of gallium
nitride his method called
the to flow MOCVD is still used to this
day from this and discoveries of other
Japanese scientists around that time he
was able to produce the first brightly
shining blue LED Nietzsche is still a
leader in the LED industry used by Apple
and other electronics manufacturers in
2014
Shuji Nakamura was awarded the Nobel
Prize in Physics for his invention along
with two other Japanese scientists who
developed high quality gallium nitride
materials prior to Nakamura's
through the small energy-efficient and
extremely bright LEDs started a light
revolution and are now used in almost
every piece of electronics without it
much of what we use today wouldn't be
possible
it also has life-changing implications
in the developing world with LEDs solar
panels and small batteries are more than
enough to power the homes of the 1.2
billion people who lack access to
electricity most of those people are
still burning wood or gas for light
which is not only inefficient it causes
pollution it's estimated that switching
all lighting to LED would reduce annual
carbon dioxide emissions by about the
same amount as that produced by
three-quarters of the cars in the u.s.
that's a potentially bigger impact on
wind or solar power and with global
warming due to human activity generating
catastrophic effects on the planet the
desire for saving energy is bigger than
ever
you